take it easy I'm not going to gloat for
myself on this podcast come on I did
notice on your Crocs you have an
eggplant emoji
I just want to also point out
I didn't choose it it was gifted to me
not it's not an emoji what's it called
no uh well it's it's the it's the
eggplant Emoji but they're called
exhibits my girlfriend just bought me
some Crocs but again I will say I didn't
buy that for myself it was gifted to me
I didn't mention it to you yesterday but
I'm like you got an eggplant on your
Crocs bro you [__] bet I do you you
go on eggplant Croc big energy you know
what I'm saying that is so I forgot to
mention that yesterday we were walking I
was like Celtics one I recognize there's
two Lightning McQueen's on there one by
the way good ciao yeah there's a pitbull
as a Pokeball there's a Coca-Cola and I
was like wait a second what's with the
eggplant
and a Winnie the Pooh yeah